and i will tell you as much as i am  willing to defend our liberty at all  costs  there's nothing that i would  dread doing more than having to pick up  arms against a fellow american why and  the way that we can have recourse  against that is if we all passionately  demand that we have election security in  all 50 states so that clip was  ultimately taken down  uh because it obviously doesn't look  good  the fbi should be investigating madison  cawthorne understand the totality of  kawthorne he has said that he is  sometimes armed on the floor of the  house of representatives since metal  detectors have been put in i don't know  what the latest is on that  he attempted to bring a gun  onto a plane tried to carry it on with  him said oops that was a mistake  and now is saying there is going to be  bloodshed if our elections continue to  be stolen which of course they are not  the fbi should investigate  this is trumpian terror